oh how is this not cat food bacon spam
that's a way to get in anybody's heart
right you ready I'm ready you want to do
the answer oh it knows it does smell
like bacon though that's the thing with
spam you got sort of gotta weed it out a
little bit
it's very credible so it's always I can
like sort of stored in its own congealed
fat which is very fun go how is it it is
a salt slam in your face
it tastes like ham but they did the
chewing for you do you like it
no I'm regretting this I would like some
more yes please I've seen a casino
that's uh what is that I'm trying to
figure out what to see no is I think to
see a chinos like pork belly maybe let's
get in it
tangy surprisingly tangy why is it sweet
it's like candied flesh oh it's amazing
it's great I can eat this all day the
flavor of that one isn't as bad blowing
my mind over here and it's orange that's
fun hot and spicy
there's red do you like spicy things I
do you do I do but I like it won't like
this that's a spicy meat pies
you're crying but yeah this can go away
I'll grease mug hey you want this whole
thing don't you
that might be too much Freddie yes oh no
there's something weird at the end of it
like it's like an aftertaste it's just
salt and smoke weed gets so bad through
spams a weird animal black pepper click
boom whoa it smells like a Vienna
sausages it does is so much pepper oh
that's how much pepper it is Turkey wait
a minute is it actually turkey bird meat
is very different than mammal meat
smells turkey ish not the worst
that's fine no it's not I had no idea
there was more than one kind of spam I
actually loved most of it I think it's
pretty great
I never even spam before now I'm team
spam there's a sweetness and that it was
both our first but we know it's not
right for us we're gonna move along on
the side it says fully cooked
ready-to-eat cold or hot but serve warm
and enjoy serve cold then it's fine